dad would have loved him so much bindi
Irwin opens up about her engagement to
Chandler Powell and how her late father
Steve Irwin would have reacted to the
news he would have been so excited that
he's now hot about family the 21 year
old lost her famous dad in 2006 in a
wildlife accident here's me cute et's
lauren zima spoke with bindi and
Chandler shortly after announcing he had
popped the question I think that's
really challenging so it's it's kind of
one of the happiest times in my life and
also one of the most challenging it was
genuinely a bittersweet time so you know
in the moment it was so incredibly
special but then at the same time but
for me on a personal note okay there's
there's people who I really wish could
be here today for this time in my life
and and particularly dad I wish that he
could be here to be getting excited the
fact that I found my passion in life is
just so wonderful and and mom and Robert
were all giving me hugs and dad's best
night at our Australia Zoo res Mannion
he was there as well when we were all
getting photos together as a family and
he was saying how proud and excited dad
would have been to so it was really
special to have that that feeling that
dad was kind of with us in a way exactly
yeah it was kind of that bittersweet
moment but I'm just
[Music]